hines horrid rai
walsh fa vj
no no non ci credo never mais è
bellissimo
ho sentito la chiamata degli horror
arrivo bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuto
video sono faringei oggi sono
felicissimo di giocare a un horror che è
stato categorizzato come uno dei più
spaventosi di del 2018
bene le premesse sono fantastiche e già
begin 27 così storico ha poi deciderti
l'equipaggiamento all'inizio ok a tychy
scegliere equipaggiamenti all'inizio
figo consiglio non lasciare che
l'attuale sanità scenda perché fa
perdere conoscenza come la morte che sta
video già partita non è già più premi li
friendly però ok allora che bello le
candele perché alla scelta io quindi non
mi posso lamentare
va bene è bella macchina per un sacco io
che so guidare me nintendo soprattutto
mai sono andato sono fortissimo e spero
che il video vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
finalmente un oro che finisce bene
se vi è piaciuto ho lasciato un commento
mi piace io vi giuro da una vita che
sognavo di fare questa cosa c'è la
macchina stai per entrare in un posto
chissenefrega esci perfetto da questo il
gioco perfetto ci hanno messo un po a
farlo adesso ho capito perché l'hanno
categorizzato come new york del 2018 ma
io direi anche negli ultimi dieci anni
visto che avrei fatto questa esatta cosa
tutte le volte però per l'audience
facciamolo per l'audience vediamo come
sarebbe andata e così è andata come se
fossi io veramente il protagonista
sarebbe andata così quindi questo è il
realismo prima vedere invece come
sarebbe andata se il protagonista fosse
un deficiente qualunque vediamo ma
questa è la macchina io credo a j per
aprire il giornale il tuo lavoro è
quello di collezionare il più possibile
di evidenti di cose paranormali per
farlo devi imboccare demoni
collezionando dei punti facendo foto o
registrando pezzi di corpi e tracce di
sangue parlare con gli spiriti usando la
tavola i già ricordati di portare una
camera è un treppiede con the easy non
tutte cose che non conosce affatto
quando andavo a scuola
la camera esattamente dov'è camera ok
e questa la camera bello io faccio le
foto alle cose paranormali va bene e
mezzanotte comunque non vorrei dirtelo
c'è anche lo zoom ma che carina quindi
un gioco dove puoi andartene quando vuoi
e finissimo sembra che qualcuno
cercavano rifugio ma non sono riusciti a
entrare dentro la cabina e io invece ci
riuscirò rivela difficile entrare nella
cabina bassa aprì la porta io sto
sentendo sussurri comunque in questo
momento io devo trovare semplicemente
delle prove che esistano i fantasmi
tutto qua
c'è tutto qua una sega però vabbè bello
beh finora a parte un ventilatore non
vedo niente di paranormale a parte il
sangue più sangue più indizio che allora
questo e sangue
l'ho visto io però le foto vengono cioè
completamente al buio
potrebbe essere un flash magari know how
eccolo c'era il flash sono 12 che c'è il
play ma adesso sì che la foto giusto
va bene alaba però va pil e quindi
attenzione che sono sprechiamo tutto va
bene
[Musica]
a me lo sarei mai aspettato questa roba
come dal registro spiegano che ha
proprio mezza la foresta dei fan a
tavola ouija mi fa piacere che tu sia
così intelligente usata volevo video
allora sei marco merlino credo che abbia
detto rino è più stato niente quindi non
vuole non vuole parlarmi vabbè chissà
perché non ne trovo il motivo dovrei
riuscire a trovare possibilmente del dei
pezzi di carta per riuscire a utilizzare
la tavola
napoli i pezzi di carta da tavola voce
non ho capito perché eccolo domanda
aggiunta la tua lista viene adesso posso
fare una domanda con la tavola voi pepe
torniamo le domande se fai solo se trovi
pezzettini dove c'è scritta la domanda
tipo i biscotti della fortuna
vabbè fuera rue dove sei ps la risposta
è sì come si dove sei
si ok guerre a rue sa se sei al sicuro
cos'è uigea simulator ostojic ordo hanno
quasi un altro caso are you but you're
dead sei buono o cattivo non aspettatevi
io chiedo di votarmi
are you but are bad è se sat sei triste
sei buono cattivo sono triste
hines orrì tra tra i watch fa vj
no no non ci credo
nev never mai è bellissimo come è un'età
giusta risposta veramente mai guarda un
video che mai
ok vabbè allora tranquillo non fa niente
sento di passo però va bene mentre kim j
lo fanno tutti
[Applauso]
gesù cristo ma che via via ci ha
soffiato alla macchia
mi sono piegato la macchina non è
italiano però vabbè avete capito messo a
punto la macchina via bene è sempre
bello vedere il demonio e fotografarlo
sappiamo che è brutto o le foto e
sappiamo che non guarda i miei video
mannaia lui
torniamo visto che c'era il demonio ci
torniamo quindi va bene il gioco sta nel
fare più punti possibili e tornare alla
macchina senza farsi uccidere questo in
poche parole no quindi niente era che
andiamo a prendere piede di porco così
torno indietro e questo che riportano
questo è un piede di porco più o meno ok
e così apro la botola andiamo di fosso
cosa che io voglio assolutamente fare
vive di quanto sono contento di andati
sotto ma è stato bello ci vediamo domani
alla prima che sapesse riscontrare ok
come si usa per il borgo cielo alpine di
porro preso
vabbè non ho capito come si usa il piede
di porco prova ben magari non era il
piede di porco quello pensavo io ho
sempre li porto io non evoco qui nessuno
andiamo via
magari a venire gesù che c'è altra roba
lasciamola perdere se mi segue il
demonio che cosa faccio io corro perché
posso fare chissà che cosa sento dei
rumori bruttissimi e di porco per il
poco dove da milito ma mai alla morte
sono pezzi di metallo semplicemente non
so cosa servono però come sei morto
questa è un'altra domanda bella proprio
quella che non gli voglio fare mai nella
vita
questa invece quanto sei back quanti
anni hai neanche questa m'interessa
parli la pace tanto numero dopo portare
a letto spesso sei qui ma spero proprio
di no visto che è un cesso
va bene proviamo a fare gli altri due
domande piazza oggetto usa la tavola voi
ce la facciamo un po di domande ce ne
sono tantissime e lo no non manca gato
va beh come sei morto
proviamo a fargli queste domande bella è
come la storia della nostra dicendo
omicidio a sori quanti anni hai
non mi sono state in faccia mentre nei
12 54 non sei troppo vecchio
are you there beh se mi sta rispondendo
sarà qui quindi si no answer retorico io
sì lo dico io
are you good bad non vice triste wood
grazie a dio va bene è un fantasma buona
quanto buono di youlike in pole pizza me
ip come schifo noi fa mangiar tela che
scrivo ora che ho sentito dei passi che
mi stavano arrivando dentro il collo
ecco la buccia proprio quando gli stavo
chiedendo cosa ne pensate di pavin j
ma porca vacca poi aspetta un attimo
aiuto fattivo dovrà fare queste per
facebook
spesa prevista dai maya infatti che c'è
un coltello in mano che amano questa la
maniera tua mamma
vai un sorrisino per la famiglia molto
bene dai che un giorno non sarai più
così bella fatti nelle foto porco schifo
l'aido che kakà una per il calendario
per giampiero che è perfetto
abbiamo mille punti potrei anche
andarmene via dalle balle effettivamente
visto che non è proprio un posto
idilliaco però è stato un piacere
sperato di arrivare alla macchina ma e
mi segue
il buon dio è spuntato un bambino è
vabbè pure ho collezionato 1000 punti
evidenza ma non sono riuscito a portarli
a casa perché sono molto vicini ai spero
che vi sia piaciuto come al solito sfide
è piaciuto sull'argomento abbiamo mi
piace anche a vari social come
descrizione se non siete iscritti e noi
ci vediamo l'anno prossimo visto dai
ragazzi
[Musica]